[Music]
all right welcome to this special
edition of Hannity Trump versus the
radical left and tonight we start with
some pretty amazing news look at this I
doubt the media mob will be focused on
it but the Donald Trump economy just
broke another huge record for the first
time in recorded history the
african-american unemployment rate in
the United States is down to 5.5 percent
that is an all-time low and that's not
all the unemployment gap between white
Americans black Americans is also at a
record low in other words our economy is
now humming on all cylinders and
thankfully working for our entire family
all Americans president's tax cuts they
were a huge success
the president's deregulation a huge
success the new trade deals with Mexico
Canada the European Union Japan a big
win for American goods and by the way I
would expect that the deal with China is
going to be free and more fair at the
end of the day and then to top it all
off Americans are now safer look at this
nationwide violent crime is down
significantly by a lot and oh by the way
construction of the wall the biggest
unreported story this week is well
underway the president this week media
is not focused on it
Nancy Pelosi is mad after securing the
3.6 billion dollars in new funding the
wall is going up as we speak
the video on your screen is showing the
progress at the border in Yuma Arizona
oh that's from last week alone and the
president is saying we'll get 500 miles
built by the end of next year ANSI
Pelosi tonight is furious she vowed to
challenge the funding in court problem
is there are laws that we have cited on
this program as it relates to the
president legally being able to build
walls and barriers to stop drug
corridors and that law also is backed up
by something called the Constitution and
you see the Constitution says he is the
commander-in-chief and we don't want the
90% of heroine in this country that
crosses that border to enter any longer
so we can end the terrible cycle of
losing nearly 300 Americans a week Nancy
Pelosi a lot of Democrats they supported
Obama's wall but they don't support
Trump's wall that's their problem in
fact Nancy Pelosi doesn't want to
address the crisis on our southern
border at all and even though today by
the way in her own state of California
look at this Nancy just like we showed a
mile from your house needles
urination defecation problems an illegal
immigrant accused of shooting police
officers was just apprehended after a
high-speed pursuit now here's another
problem
miss Pelosi madam Speaker if you are
speaker in name only
he was previously released allegedly
because of California's cities and their
state sanctuary laws Oh
in other words aiding and abetting those
people that already committed crimes and
not handing him over to ice to be
deported and meanwhile in Maryland look
at this six illegal immigrants one u.s.
citizen just charged and the stabbing
death of a 21 year old now according to
statistics from the administration
during a two-year period four thousand
murders were committed by illegal
immigrants in this country 100 thousand
results carried out Oh 30,000 sexual
crimes carried out each and every week
heroin is killing opioids are killing
approximately 300 Americans 90 percent
of heroin and now fentanyl are coming in
through our southern border this is a
national security crisis the president
he's absolutely right to make the border
a priority and that means we can prevent
those drugs from getting in the hands of
American kids now the president is also
dedicated to improving the quality of
life for everyone in this country and by
the way for all you conservatives that
said Hannity is just supporting the
president said no the president didn't
give up on the border wall he just
changed strategies and I've now been
proven correct because the money has
been reallocated it is legal it is
constitutional now despite significant
gains and safety security prosperity of
Americans here at home you got Democrats
their number one supporters contributors
allies and the media mob they are
seething with anger and pessimism and
despair and even hoping for recessions
openly if you watch the terrible climate
oh my gosh seven-hour disaster is
marathon on fake news CNN this
you are democrats mourning the
destruction of planet earth because of
the evils of capitalism and plastic
straws and oh the combustion engine
others on the left are actively using
the politics of race and division of
stoke fear among american voters and
divide us that is a classic political
tactic from democrats and the media mob
but this year it's even more depraved
than ever look at this for example
member former ESPN commentator Jamil
Hill wrote an article calling for
voluntary racial segregation and college
sports in order to quote disrupt the
reign of an amateur sports system that
uses the labor of quote black folks to
make quote white folks rich
now while Hill is using the politics of
race to divide this country one
prominent author is stoking fear
resentment surrounding anybody who dares
to wear any red hat any red hat no
writing on it have the pollster
nominated author tweeting quote if
anyone else made really uncomfortable
these days by anyone wearing any kind of
red baseball cap like I see on my heart
does weird bleep and I finally realize
it only says Titleist or whatever maybe
don't wear red caps anymore normal
people I like red caps and by the way if
you're a Boston Red Sox fan and a
Cincinnati Reds fan apparently your
team's hats are scaring the snow flakes
they might think you might be one of us
smelly Walmart shoppers I love Walmart I
love Costco all of those stores are
great you know why you saved money get
the same products and irredeemable
deplorable z' that likes our president
that likes the success for to having
that likes the economy that's creating
jobs and getting people off of food
stamps I've made us energy independent
for the first time in 75 years
sadly Trump derangement syndrome it's
become so bad Trump donors they're now
being targeted with harassment in public
shaming and boycotts former press
secretary Sarah Sanders now a Fox News
contributor we're glad to have her a
private citizen still confronted in
public by angry psychotic Trump hating
lunatics take a look you're out of the
administration now
you still take in heat when you go out
to eat sometimes you know it usually
depends on where I am in the country
back home in Arkansas things have so far
been pretty easy and very welcoming
about here in New York City it's it's
hit or miss I have not been asked to
leave any restaurant thankfully but
every once in a while you always you
know you have somebody who comes up to
say something nasty to you now the
vilification of political differences
that's got to stop no one deserves to be
harassed in their private lives
unfortunately the mob and the media is
constantly stoking well this resentment
because they just hate Trump every
second minute hour of every 24-hour day
every week every month every year
Russia Russia stormy stormy races racist
impeachment impeachment sharp e sharp e
sharp E is the latest that insane
obsessive non-stop hysteria over drawing
a map according to News Buster's on
Wednesday fake news CNN and yes
MSDN see the conspiracy network
dedicated a whopping hundred and
forty-five minutes of airtime to Sharpie
coverage and analysis and of course the
breath was hysterical reporting an
attempt to make the president look bad
that's what they do
they're the ones who appear detached
from reality they're the ones that
pretty much have pushed every lie
conspiracy theory and a hoax for two and
a half years as the media mob not know
how insane they look do they even care
apparently not and now totally blinded
by this anti Trump rage if Donald Trump
cured cancer I doubt they would say a
good thing about it the left's lunacy
has now reached an all-time low